Okay. So, Michael, I want to go into some algorithms,
or at least some classes of algorithms but before we do
that, I think it's useful to really ask a very simple
question, which is exactly how hard is this problem. And to
help answer that we're going to do a quiz, because you
like quizzes, and I'm going to define my terms just a
little bit better but maybe not that much better. So, here's
the quiz. You've got a set of data with N features.
And your goal is to find a subset of M
features. Where the size of that subset is no greater than
the original subset. Which makes sense. The original set of
features in which makes sense. Okay? And that's it. And so,
what I want you to be able to tell me
is given this generic problem of starting with N features and
finding a subset of M features How long does it
take in terms of time complexity to do. Is it linear,
quadratic, polynomial, or exponential nm?
>> Polynomial includes linear quadratic so you mean
sort of of polynomial that's not linear quadratic.
>> That's right and I mean quadratic as not linear.
>> Got it.
>> And I mean exponential that's not polynomial or quadratic or linear.
>> It's not.
>> Well it could be. You could have 2 to the
n plus n squared for example, times 0. You could do it.
Don't mess with me man. Okay, so you got the problem?
>> Just to make sure I understand. So, so, can
you draw like a rectangle? Like our input space x?
>> Okay. So we've got some input space x. This is a rectangle.
>> And it's got n features, so those are like the columns.
>> Okay.
>> Alright. And we're going to select a subset
m of those n features. So we'll have
a like, a skinnier matrix, but not shorter.
>> Mm-hm. Right.
>> Alright, so and, can I choose any way I want to to define what
subsets I like better than which other subsets,
because then I can do this really fast.
>> So what we're going to do is there's going to be some function,
let's just call it F, okay, which given a set of features,
return a score. Oh, that looks sort of familiar.
>> Mm-hm. And this function may be arbitrarily complicated, it
may be really simple, but you don't know what it is.
>> Oh. Alright. Then I think, I think I can answer this question now.
>> Okay, so let's go.